what we're going to do in this video is
think about how shapes properties might
be preserved or not preserved from
dilations and so here we have this
quadrilateral and we're going to dilate
it about point p here and i have this
little dilation dilation tool so the
first question is are the coordinates of
the vertices going to be preserved
well pause the video and try to think
about that well let's just try it out
experimentally we can see under an
arbitrary dilation here the coordinates
are not preserved the point that
corresponds to d has is now has a
different coordinate the vertices the
vertex that corresponds to a now has
different coordinates same thing for b
and c the corresponding points after the
dilation now sit on a different part of
the coordinate coordinate plane so in
this case the coordinates of the
vertices are not preserved
now the next question let me go back to
where we were
so the next question the corresponding
line segments after dilation are they
sitting on the same line
and so let me dilate again
and so you can see if you consider this
point b prime because it corresponds to
point b the segment b prime
c prime this does not sit on the same
line as bc
but the segment a prime d prime the
corresponding line segment to line
segment a d that does sit on the same
line and if you think about it why that
is well if we originally
draw
a line that if we look at the
line that contains segment a d it also
goes through point p and so as we expand
out this segment right over here is
going to expand and shift outward along
the same lines but that's not going to
be a true of these other segments
because they don't because the point p
does not sit on the line that those
segments sit on and so let's just expand
it again so you see that right over
there
now the next question are angle measures
preserved
well it looks like they are and this is
one of the things that is true about a
dilation is that you're going to
preserve angle measures this angle is
still a right angle this angle here
i guess you could call it angle the
measure of angle b is the same as the
measure of angle b prime and you can see
it with all of these points right over
there
and then the last question are side
lengths perimeter and area preserved
well we can immediately see as we dilate
outwards for example the segment
corresponding to ad has gotten longer in
fact if we dilate outwards all of the
segments the corresponding segments are
getting larger and if they're all
getting larger then the perimeter is
getting larger and the area is getting
larger likewise if we dilate in like
this they're all getting smaller so side
lengths perimeter and area are not
preserved
now let's ask the same questions with
another dilation and this is going to be
interesting because we're going to look
at a dilation that is centered at one of
the vertices of our shape
so let me scroll down here
and so
i have the same tool again and now here
we have a triangle triangle abc and
we're going to dilate about point c
so first of all do we think the vertices
the coordinates of the vertices are
going to be preserved
let's dilate out
well you can see
point c is preserved it when it gets
mapped after the dilation it sits in the
exact same place but the things that
correspond to a and b are not preserved
you could call this a prime and this
definitely has different coordinates
than a and b prime definitely has
different coordinates than b
now what about corresponding line
segments are they on the same line
well some of them are and some of them
aren't so for example
when we dilate so look at let's look at
the segment ac and the segment bc
when we dilate
we can see whoops when we dilate we can
see the corresponding segments you could
call this a prime
c prime or b prime c prime do still sit
on that same line
and that's because the point that we are
dilating about point c sat on those
original segments so we're essentially
just lengthening out on on the point
that is not the center of dilation we're
lengthening out away from it or if the
dilation is going in we would be
shortening along that same line
but some of the segments are not
overlapping on the same line so for
example a prime b prime does not sit
along the same line as a b
now what about the angle measures
well we already talked about it angle
measures are preserved under dilations
the measure of angle c here this is the
exact same angle and so is the measure
of angle you could call this a prime and
b prime right over here
and then finally what about side lengths
well you can clearly see that when i
dilate out my side lengths increase or
if i dilate in my side lengths decrease
and so side lengths are not preserved
and if side lengths are not preserved
then the perimeter is not preserved and
also the area is not preserved you could
view area as a function of the side
lengths if we dilate out like this the
perimeter grows and so does the area if
we dilate in like this the perimeter
shrinks and so does the area